Eric Adams described how our schools
specifically schools in New York City
have plummeted to such depths of
degradation if we are bringing our best
fight in the ring we would not have
homeless in this city we would not have
a crisis of domestic violence we would
not have children because when we took
prayers out of schools guns came into
schools yeah that's right he's not
giving an historical study here he's
making a philosophical and
anthropological point this is how human
beings work when you stop them from
worshiping God and turning their eyes up
to good things and to Virtue they're
going to turn it somewhere else they're
going to turn their attention to bad
things they're going to turn their
attention to false Idols they're going
to turn their attention to falsehoods
and advice that is what's going to
happen because we live in time and space
we're human beings we got to do
something